all right we finally have some new
details about Spider-Man freshman year
including a release date and a new
synopsis for the first episode and for
the series overall now so far we have
seen some absolutely incredible artwork
for the upcoming show fans are super
excited for this project especially
since they announced that Matt Murdoch
AKA Daredevil is going to be joining the
show and Charlie Cox Daredevil himself
is even going to be voicing the
character and with the new information
that we've gotten over the past couple
of days we've learned about even more
characters that are going to be showing
up during Spider-Man freshman year this
along with our new plot synopsis and
what Marvel Studios Executives have told
us before we have a pretty good idea of
what Spider-Man freshman year is going
to be about and we'll tell you
everything you need to know about this
upcoming Marvel Studios Disney plus
Series in this video and if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news also so
you can enter our givea away for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner picks one item and we
pick a winner at the end of each month
all you got to do is subscribe and leave
a comment on our videos so some of you
may have heard that recently Marvel
Studios has filed some of their
properties with the US copyright office
in these filings which are public a lot
of information about the projects filed
can be found for Spider-Man freshman
year it specifically talks about episode
101 so we assume that this is going to
be the first episode for type of work
pre-registered it states motion picture
and then for application title and
regular title it states Spider-Man
freshman year episode 101 101 and here's
where it gives us an approximate release
state it says creation of work began in
2022 March 25th the date of anticipated
completion is December 15th of 2023 this
year not too long from now and the
projected date of publication or the
release date is currently scheduled for
November 2nd of 2024 so about a year
away a little bit over a year so not too
long we didn't really know when we were
going to get the show thanks to all the
delays and the schedule shifts and
luckily for us there is actually a lot
happening in 2024 to hold us over until
we get this show but that is the
approximate release date that Marvel
Studios filed with the copyright office
now a part of this is also a description
of the plot of which is apparently just
for the first episode since the first
episode episode 101 is the one being
registered here and here's what it says
under description of work it states
description of the work Marvel Studios
presents Spider-Man freshman year in
which Peter Parker's life while getting
ready for his high school orientation is
forever changed by events that send him
on a journey like none before and this
is obviously his Spider-Man Journey
although it does have a Twist to it
which we'll get to in a second it
continues to state in the first episode
we discover that the new era of
Spider-Man begins here okay so a new era
of Spider-Man one that we haven't seen
before in the MCU and this does take
place in a separate Universe not the
main Earth 616 Universe we'll talk about
that in a bit but part of this
description is the main cast it States
main cast includes Hudson themes as
Peter Parker Eugene bird as Lonnie
Lincoln Grace song as Nico minoru Hugh
Dancy as Otto octavus so Doc O Carrie
Walgren as Aunt May and Zeno Robinson as
Harry Osborne so let's go through these
characters real quick Bonnie Lincoln is
Tombstone Tombstone is an albino bully
at Peter Parker's School in high school
and then when they grow up he becomes a
mob enforcer in Philadelphia and from
there he would become a typical mob boss
murderer Nico or sister Grim who she
goes by in the comics is a powerful
wizard who also had parents who were
powerful Wizards as well but they were
evil and eventually they died
sacrificing themselves to save her and
other children as well I'm curious to
see how her story is going to fit in
Spider-Man freshman year but excited
nonetheless and I think we all know Otto
Octavius Doc O we all should know Aunt
May and Harry Osborne as well now what's
different about Spider-Man freshman year
as I mentioned is this is actually kind
of a separate multiversal project it
does not take place in the earth 616
universe and this info is coming
directly from Brad wer bomb an executive
at Marvel Studios and when talking about
Spider-Man freshman year at San Diego
Comic-Con and then again in interviews
down the road he said that it follows
the pattern that you see in Captain
America Civil War down to Peter getting
the broken Blu-ray player however
there's one really big change we'll talk
about that in just a bit but first big
thank you to hellofresh for sponsoring
this video many of you probably know by
now that I personally use hellofresh a
lot because for me it simply makes sense
I have a pretty busy schedule in my
day-to-day life and hellofresh just
makes eating good meals a lot easier for
me with over 40 different recipes that I
could choose from each week hellofresh
does all the shopping and meal planning
for you ingredients arrive at your
doorstep pre-portioned and ready to cook
along with pictured step-by-step recipe
cards they literally make it as easy as
it possibly could be the meals are very
quick to make and they do include some
15minute meals as well it takes the
hassle out of meal time but it also can
save you money hellofresh is cheaper
than groc shopping and 25% less
expensive than takeout that means less
stress of worrying about what you're
going to eat and you save money so if
interested go to hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com sl50 Cosmic and use code
50 Cosmic for 50% off plus free shipping
so Brad witer bomb says it goes down to
Peter getting the broken Blu-ray player
from the trash and he walks into his
apartment for the famous moment where
Tony Tony Stark is waiting for him to
offer him the Stark internship and take
him to Berlin but he States but because
of things that happen in the Multiverse
because of new random occurrences it's
not Tony Stark who's waiting for him
there it's Norman Osborne and that send
his life in an unexpected trajectory
that collides Him With Many unexpected
characters in the Marvel universe so
this is a very interesting story because
it's almost sort of like a what if what
if Norman Osborne was Spider-Man's
mentor and not Tony Stark except for it
being an episode it's an entire series
and one could see how this could be
pretty appealing because if Norman
Osborne is going to be Peter Parker's
Mentor then perhaps he is going to have
to take him out at some point in time if
he's going to go on to become the Green
Goblin then Spider-Man will probably
fight him or perhaps Harry Osborne who
we've seen become the Green Goblin more
than once plus we have Daredevil coming
in and it's rumored that Kingpin might
be in the show as well also voiced by
his liveaction counterpart Vinnie denafo
which would be awesome since he's
already made his MCU debut in the
Hawkeye series and is returning for Ekko
and the liveaction Daredevil Born Again
series and speaking of the liveaction
Daredevil Born Again series we do also
have a plot synopsis and a approximate
release date for that show as well on
the copyright that was filed the release
date was slated for January of 2025 so
pretty much right when Spider-Man
freshman year ends Daredevil born again
will start and here's what it says for
the episode one synopsis Marvel Studios
presents Daredevil in which longtime
Rivals Matt Murdoch and Wilson Fisk try
to leave behind their darker alter egos
to serve the people of New York only to
have their past catch up to them in the
first episode of the series we are
reintroduced to the world of Daredevil
that's a very interesting word they use
they reintroduced to the world of
Daredevil this implies that it's really
not a reboot but might be more of a
continuation just kind of down a
separate path than the Netflix series we
have a lot of returning cast members
including John Bernthal is the Punisher
and it looks like this synopsis has
confirmed recent reports that Wilson
Fisk AKA Kingpin is going to be the
mayor of New York City in Daredevil Born
Again perhaps he was doing that to
Simply leave behind his past and then it
catches up with him or could he still be
doing that to have even more power as a
criminal boss born again is one of the
projects I am most excited about and so
is Spider-Man freshman year so go ahead
and let us know your thoughts about both
of these projects in the comments down
below what do you think about all the
news we heard today let us know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date with all
things in the MCU you can also find us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof